we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 David P you can call any time of
day here is a caller who is calling me
out how do I care about the environment
and yet I flew
on an airplane
okay let's take a listen
bagel
did I hear how many flights you've been
doing
500 gallons per hour
please put your carbon footprint usage
next to you super cool I voted blue
check mark yeah a check mark I've never
displayed
and when you see Pete the incompetent
selling our holes in some serious
filling
a little bit of that hot asphalt
breastfeeding Road reparations
should we go a long way to drive my
pretty little Tesla on
Tesla
you do okay work but you you got to work
some things out on your
on on your geological trees you got from
coughing up to do I think that that is
anti-Semitic I've got to figure some
things out work some things out on my
genealogical tree I can only imagine
that's an anti-semitic comment
anyways other than that you're somewhat
acceptable
bye let's see how much fuel you burnt
last year you silly willy okay listen so
I've heard this before okay you care
about the environment and yet you still
utilize transportation and purchase food
to metabolize into energy to sustain
Homo sapiens I mean listen
um caring about the environment doesn't
mean you give up every form of
transportation or any activity that has
a carbon foot run okay and I don't know
that anybody holds themselves or others
to that standard caring about the
environment means you advocate for more
sustainable and efficient Alternatives
renewable energy sources carbon offsets
public transit
Etc and you've got these right Wingers
who love to criticize leftists so you
flew in an airplane it's a logical
fallacy or you flew in an airplane
it's an appeal to hypocrisy what they
are actually doing and uh this is when
you try to discredit an argument by
pointing out its inconsistency that the
person making the argument is
inconsistent you are are uh inconsistent
because you say you care about the
environment yet you drove a car
or you traveled on an airplane they
don't actually address the argument
itself it doesn't actually invalidate
the argument that we are making
the argument they seem to be making
implicitly is people on the left
shouldn't have cars of any kind
they should never travel by airplane
cell phones have conflict minerals I
guess no cell phones plus the cell phone
gets shipped so that's it gets shipped
on an airplane you know so that that
that's a carbon footprint you I guess
according to these people have to live
like an ascetic to really be a
consistent liberal or something like
that the reality of course is people on
the left drive cars and have cell phones
they're not Hypocrites by their very
nature simply because they care about
the environment we are using the
available technology and infrastructure
that Society provides should I be biking
to my brother's wedding in California
should I not be going because I'm on the
left and I care about the environment or
whatever the case may be and by the way
I'm aware of the negative impacts of
those products and I support efforts to
reduce that electric vehicles is a step
recycling is a step ethical sourcing is
another I know people will write to me
and they'll say David some forms of
recycling
actually have a larger carbon footprint
depending on that how it's done I'm
aware of that recycling when it reduces
the carbon footprint liberals who drive
cars or have cell phones aren't
responsible for the economic uh
environmental rather damage that
corporations
caused by virtue of their products and
services we want to hold the
corporations accountable for their
actions we want to pressure them to
adopt more environmentally friendly
practices and policies and all of it so
when I have a phone or I fly on an
airplane I'm not ignoring the
environmental problems uh I am actively
involved in raising awareness about
those problems donating campaigning for
more sustainable options and solutions
and in fact we often use those tools to
raise awareness I use my phone to get
the word out about these things that I
believe I sometimes draw drive or fly to
events at which I advocate for these
things so this appeal to hypocrisy
fallacy from these people who have
absolutely nothing to offer on their own
of any substance or productivity uh they
barely deserve attention so okay I
addressed it here now we can go back to
ignoring them we have such a great bonus
show for you today a David Pac-Man
membership coach six bucks a month it
does but if you use a coupon code it's
cheaper we are going to talk about the
hottest day in history which took place
this week on today's bonus show and by
the way the record is going to be broken
again we are going to talk about Central
Park five member Youssef salaam willing
winning the New York City council's
Democratic primary and we are also going
to talk about radical and repugnant
Republican Congressman Matt Gates
proposing to end Cannabis Testing for
the military something I actually agree
with why is he doing it well maybe he
just believes it's the right thing all
of those stories and more will be on
today's bonus show oh the bonus show
where you
you can access the bonus show with a
number of different machines we're doing
a class action loss
right in all seriousness it doesn't have
to end right now there is more show
available today you don't have to wait
until tomorrow sign up at joinpakman.com
you'll get instant access and I will be
joined by producer Pat see you then or
we'll be back here tomorrow